we'd like to examine the motion of two
particles here's particle 1 and here's
particle 2 and each particle can have
some motion in between them is the
center of mass and what we'd like to do
is figure out how to describe the motion
of each of these particles with respect
to the center of mass so let's choose
some coordinate system origin down here
here's our particle R 1 here's our
particle R 2 and here is our center of
mass now in the reference frame of the
center of mass we have position vector R
1 prime and we have position vector R 2
prime and what we'd like to do is find
expressions for R 1 prime in our 2 prime
in terms of the positions of R 1 and R 2
now we're call that the position of the
center of mass for this two body problem
is given by M 2 m 1 R 1 plus M 2 R 2
divided by the total mass and here we
use the vector triangle that R 1 prime
equals R 1 minus our center of mass now
remember this vector is equal to this
vector minus that vector sometimes
people like to say the vector R 1 is
equal to R plus R prime and that's how
we get that relationship now we can use
our result here that R 1 prime is R 1
minus m1 r1 plus m2 r2 divided by m1
plus m2 and when we combine terms let's
just do this so you can see it R 1 minus
m1 r1 plus m2 r2 divided by the total
mass we now have the m1 r1 terms cancel
and we have a common m2 over m1 plus m2
times r1 minus r2 now r1 minus r2 is a
vector that goes from here's R 1 here's
R 2 so the vector
r1 - r2 is the relative position of
vector 1 with respect to 2 and let's
give that a special name we'll call that
r12 the relative position vector so we
have m2 over m1 plus m2 r12 is r1 prime
now you can easily see that if you
interchange the indices 1 & 2
the only thing that changes here is a
sign and if we interchange 1 & 2 and
this is an exercise that you can do then
r2 prime is minus m1 I'm interchanging
the Innis indices the minus sign came
from the interchange of 1 & 2 and so we
get M 1 over m 1 plus M 2 with the minus
sign
r12 now what is the significance of this
result if you know the position of r1
and r2
you know the relative velocity if you
have information about this relative
position if you know the relative
position vector then you can separately
get the locations of the two objects in
the center-of-mass frame now this
quantity in here will appear often and
I'd like to introduce a new quantity
called the reduced mass and that reduced
mass mu is the product of m1 m2 over m1
plus m2 it's a simple exercise to see
that 1 over mu is 1 over m 1 plus 1 over
m + 2 and we'll encounter that a little
bit later then I can write both of these
vectors and this is our conclusion that
r1 prime is the reduced mass notice we
have an M 2 here so we have to divide by
m 1 times the vector R 1 2 and our 2
prime is - the reduced mass again we now
have to divide by M 2 and you see this
nice symmetry of M 1 and 1/2 + 2 R 1
and that's our key result